It may actually be an understatement to call
Matt Damon a prolific actor.
He's in dozens of movies, including "Good
Will Hunting," "Saving Private Ryan," and
the "Bourne" franchise.
He's long been considered one of the most
successful actors in Hollywood, thanks to
his impressive range, likable screen presence,
and other talents — don't forget that he
wrote "Good Will Hunting" with Ben Affleck.
“How do you like them apples?"
Damon has endured some rough patches, of course,
but he remains an integral part of the film
industry.
Back in 2007, Damon was named Hollywood's
most bankable star, with the CBC reporting,
"For every dollar he was paid for his last
three roles, Damon brought in $29 U.S. of
gross income."
Aside from his many great films, Damon has
been part of several projects that didn't
quite live up to expectations.
From flops like "Suburbicon" to movies that
got mostly average reviews, such as "Titan
A.E.," Damon has seen every side of a movie's
possible critical reception.
Thankfully for him, one of his less popular
movies, a wartime action thriller based on
a nonfiction book, is getting another chance
on Netflix — and so far, it's staying high
on the streaming platform's trending list.
The 2010 movie "Green Zone" was inspired by
the book "Imperial Life in the Emerald City,"
written by journalist Rajiv Chandrasekaran.
The book describes what it was like within
the Green Zone, the International Zone of
Baghdad, during the 2003 U.S. invasion of
Iraq, and in the subsequent transfer of power.
"Green Zone," which reunites Damon with "Bourne
Supremacy" and "Bourne Ultimatum" director
Paul Greengrass, follows U.S. Army Chief Warrant
Officer Roy Miller, played by Damon, who realizes
that the intelligence the Pentagon is receiving
is faulty, as all of their leads for weapons
of mass destruction end up going nowhere.
Miller decides to take things into his own
hands and begins hunting for WMD on his own,
while uncovering some harsh truths along the
way.
"Green Zone" won over about half of critics,
with a rating of 53% on Rotten Tomatoes, but
it was considered a flop at the box office.
Some critics said that "Green Zone" strayed
a bit too far from the truth, but others appreciated
its commentary on the motivation behind the
war in Iraq.
Andrew O'Hagan of The Evening Standard went
so far as to call it "one of the best war
films ever made."
He added,
"It exposed the terrible lies that stood behind
the decision of the U.S. and Britain to prosecute
the war, and it does so in a way that is dramatically
brilliant, morally complex and relentlessly
thrilling."
The majority of recent viewers have positive
things to say about "Green Zone," with some
taking to social media to offer their compliments.
One Twitter user said they consider it to
be an "underrated action movie," and yet another
confessed that they "enjoyed it more than
[they] expected to."
Others have commented on how "Green Zone"
shines a light on the conspiracies surrounding
the war in Iraq, adding that Damon's stellar
performance introduces another layer of excitement.
"You wanna sit around and dig holes all day?
I wanna get something done."
Audience critiques on Rotten Tomatoes also
mostly lean positive, with almost all in agreement
that Damon's acting is a strong point of the
film.
One reviewer succinctly said,
"I'm a fan of Matt Damon, he is perfectly
satisfactory in the role of Roy Miller; he
holds things together."
When asked about how accurate the film actually
is during a 2010 interview, Damon told Collider
that some real-life people had to be boiled
down to one central character to make the
story work better.
He said:
"There were no weapons in Iraq.
That's true.
A lot of people went there thinking there
were.
That's true, too.
No one's really explained what the f--- happened.
That's true too.
[...] I mean, what we have in the movie is,
yeah, we have a guy playing kind of a neocon
type who actually invented a source, right?
So that's not based on anything, that's obviously
something that, for the movie, for the kind
of architecture of a thriller to work, it
needs to boil down to a couple characters."
Fans of the "Bourne" franchise's action-packed
plot lines will likely enjoy seeing Damon
in another thrilling role, while history and
politics buffs will appreciate the social
commentary of "Green Zone."
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about movies
on Netflix are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.